lo tengo tuiteó el rover de la nasa
percibirán de misión en marte en su
segundo intento percibidas logró
recolectar muestras de roca bastante
sólidas para realizar estudios
se trata de un verdadero logro histórico
son las primeras rocas recogidas de otro
planeta terrestre es increíble esas dos
muestras de roca también contiene la
atmósfera marciana
más firme en los primeros análisis de
esos elementos se identificó presencia
de sal las gonzález son grandes
minerales para preservar signos de vida
antigua aquí en la tierra y esperamos
que lo mismo puede hacer para las rocas
de marte el módulo que transportaba
percibirás aterrizó el 18 de febrero en
el cráter de ge 0 donde científicos
piensan que hace 3.500 millones de años
se encontraba un profundo lago un
entorno que hubiera podido crear
condiciones necesarias para la vida
extraterrestre la voluntad de enviar
humanos a marte es muy fuerte creo que
lo haremos de una manera u otra y una
vez que entendamos el entorno de marte y
logremos determinar si hubo no vida en
el pasado eso nos permitirá saber a
dónde iremos y cómo lo haremos la semana
pasada la nasa había anunciado que
posiblemente había logrado recolectar
muestras útiles para un análisis pero
debido a la falta de luz en las imágenes
no se alcanzaba a ver si lo habían
conseguido o no estos próximos años
percibirán continuará recolectando
muestras que dejara selladas en el suelo
marciano hasta 2030 cuando se espera su
traslado a la tierra